هذا ورفض نتنياهو ما نشرته صحيفه ول ستريت
جورنال عن وجود مقترح لصفقه تبادل للاسرى
يشمل انسحاب اسرائيل من قطاع غزه وقال
نتنياهو انه يرفض رفضا قاطعا لمقترح لانه
بمثابه مطالبه لاسرائيل بالاستسلام معتبرا
استمرار الضغط العسكري السبيل الوحيد
لاستعاده الرهائن الاسرائيليين كما قال ب
خ بخصوص المختطفين قمنا باعاده م وع منهم
الى الوطن حتى الان ونحن ملتزمون باعادته
جميعا وهذا احد اهداف الحرب والضغط
العسكري شرط ضروري لاتمام ذلك انا اعمل من
اجل ذلك على مدار الساعه ولكن لكي نكون
واضحين انا ارفض بشكل قاطع شروط الاستسلام
التي يضعها وحوش حماس هم يريدون مقابل
اطلاق سراح رهائن انهاء الحرب وانسحاب
قواتنا من غزه واطلاق سراح جميع القتله
والمغتصب
من جماعه النخبه وترك حماس سليمه اذا
وافقنا على ذلك فقد سقط محاربون سدن واذا
وافقنا على ذلك فلن نتمكن من ضمان امن
مواطننا